sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und
Herren man muss schon nach der
Regierungserklärung von Bundeskanzler
oder Scholz konstatieren auch von Herrn
März dass sie komplett an den Sorgen und
Problemen vor all des eigenen Landes
vorbei argumentiert haben Frau
Hasselmann ihre Rede war eine reine
Kriegsrede nichts anderes hat mich
wirklich
erschüttert und da braucht man sich
nicht wundern dass immer mehr Bürger mit
Sorge und auch mit wirklich
Unverständnis auf diese Bundesregierung
blicken und wenn man sich die Halbzeit
dieser Bundesregierung anguckt und die
ist ja jetzt gegeben da muss man
wirklich sagen wie dieses Land kaputt
gewirtschaftet wird das gab es nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg noch nie in diesem
Land innerhalb wirklich von weniger
Monate ist diese Wirtschaftsnation
Deutschland maßgeblich verändert worden
durch diese Bundesregierung Inflation
schrumpfende Wirtschaft steigende ins
und als Krönung wird Ihnen durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht bestätigt dass
ihr sonderschuldenhaushalt als nicht
verfassungsgemäß erklärt wurde und ihre
Schlussfolgerung daraus das haben wir
heute wieder gehört sie lassen sich
nicht beirren und laufen genauso immer
weiter mit KTF offenen Auges in die
Sackgasse so sieht aktuelle Politik
dieser Regierung aus und die SPD für die
da hören wir auf dem Parteitag
Sozialausgaben gehört ja zur DNA der SPD
usgaben die mittlerweile zutiefst
unsozial sind weil sie nicht mehr die
Notlagen einzelner abfedern sondern in
Form des bürgergildes einer Art
Grundeinkommen darstellen und dieses ist
weder an Bedingungen geknüpft noch
motiviert ist eine teilweise schlechter
bezahlte Arbeit aufzunehmen und damit
etwas für den sozialstadt überhaupt zu
tun sie sehen Werte Kollegen diese
Politik schafft weiterhin einseitige
Abhängigkeiten und eben keine Innovation
und Herr Bundeskanzler wir wissen ja die
sind nicht der Mann der vielen Worte sie
werden vielleicht als der ewig
schweigende Kanzler in die Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik eingehen ihnen sind
nicht nur die Information zur
warbrurgbank abhanden gekommen sie sind
in ihrem Kabinett auch keine Ideen die
wir wahrnehmen was sie eigentlich mit
diesem Deutschland anfangen wollen und
das haben wir auch heute wieder nicht
gehört die ganze Welt wollen sie retten
und das Klima noch dazu aber das können
doch nicht wirklich die einzigen Ziele
einer deutschen Bundesregierung sein die
Bürger in diesem Land die Bürger in
diesem
Land die ganz oben auf der Agenda stehen
und in ihrem Wahlkampf haben sich selbst
immer wieder von Respekt gesprochen und
wo bleibt der Respekt für diejenigen die
in diesem Land wirtschaftlich tätig sein
für den Mittelstand für das Handwerk für
die Industrie stattdessen verknappen sie
künstlich die Energieversorgung sie
schalten intakte Kernkraftwerke ab
lassen mit den Anschlägen auf nordstream
zu dass unsere kritische Infrastruktur
zerstört wird und stoppen den Import
russischen Gases und der
Wirtschaftsminister führt hier seinen
grünen Wirtschafts Krieg innerhalb
Deutschlands und in der ganzen Welt und
diesen wird er auch nicht gewinnen
bislang versagt er damit wie die
Wirtschaftssanktionen ja gegen Russland
zeigen diese haben nur zur Folge und das
sehen wir ja aktuell dass die russische
Wirtschaft steigt und unsere schrumpft
das ist aktuell der stand heute denkt
fast jedes zweite größere Unternehmen
über Abwanderung aus Deutschland nach
und jedes dritte sitzt bereits auf GEP
gepackten Koffern dazu kein Wort von
Ihnen Herr Bundeskanzler und mit den
steigen
CO2 Preisen die Sie heute schon
verkündet haben machen sie die deutschen
Wirtschaftsstandort noch unattraktiver
Industrieverbände warnen vor
Deindustrialisierung das hat die
Alternative für Deutschland schon vor
Jahren getan und da wurde uns
Verschwörungstheorien vorgeworfen das
war ihre Aussage damals gewesen und wenn
man sieht die CO2 Abgabe so wie Frau
Hasselmann ja gerade gesagt habe von
wegen Subvention gekürzt wird dann nicht
um 30 € die Tonne steigen sondern um 45
€ damit wird weiter die Inflation
nächstes Jahr angeheizt und dieser
Wirtschaftsstandort wird weiter ruiniert
das ist ihre Politik und die werden wir
verhindern das kann ich Ihnen
versprechen meine Damen und Herren
deutschland braucht endlich eine
wohlstandspolitik im Interesse der
Bürger und deshalb braucht es auch
endlich haushalterisch einen Kassensturz
unnötige Ausgaben die müssen weichen und
dazu gehört der ganze Themenkomplex
Ukraine und was wir heute und was ich
hier heute gehört habe macht mich
wirklich ein Stück weit fassungslos
jährlich 6 Millionen Euro aktuell
Bürgergeld für 700.000 Ukrainer bis zum
Jahr 2027 weitere 17 Milliarden Euro für
Waffenlieferung 5 Milliarden für den
Wiederaufbau und wenn man heute gehört
hat auch was sie im Europarat ja
besprechen wollen schließt das auch die
geplanten Beitritt der der Ukraine zur
EU ein 130 Milliarden Euro wird das
kosten das hat das Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft berechnet 130
Milliarden Euro und das werden wir
wieder natürlich als hauptfinanz er
finanzieren müssen diese Ausgaben sollen
nun vor allen Dingen aus dem
regelhaushalt bestritten werden und da
sieht man wie diese Ukraine Notlage die
sie im Prinzip heute schon angekündigt
haben für das nächste Jahr in Zukunft
geplant werden soll und da werden auch
zukünftige eventuelle Zahlungsausfälle
anderer Länder das haben sie heute ja
schon gesagt mit übernommen hier sieht
man dass wir immer mehr zur Kriegspartei
werden und das können wir wirklich nicht
zulassen dass wir uns weiter an den Hals
der Ukraine werfen und hier als
alleiniger Zahler und Kriegspartei uns
mitverantwortlich machen für Ehen und
Leid in dieser
Region und wir sehen ja aktuell gucken
wir uns in der USA um die usreublikaner
blockieren im Senat ein Milliardenpaket
für die Ukraine und auch für Israel weil
die US-Bürger eben nicht mehr Geld für
fremde Kriege ausgeben wollen und das
wollen auch die deutschen Bürger nicht
mehr wir brauchen keine konstruierten
Feindbilder und Brandmauern wir brauchen
endlich und das ist das was auch die
Wirtschaft verlangt vernünftige
Rahmenbedingungen damit die verbliebenen
Unternehmen auch hier weiter produzieren
begreifen sie Steuersenkung als
Investitionen mit 7 Milliarden Euro
Entlastung könnten Unternehmer und auch
Endverbraucher rechnen würden sie z.B
die Erhöhung der Maut zurücknehmen um
den eigenen Haushalt zu rechtfertigen
konstruieren Sie weiter mögliche
Notlagen für das gaststätengewerbe ab
nächstes Jahr ist die Notlage ab Januar
beendet und der volle Mehrwertsteuer
Satz wird wieder fällig wir sagen 7 %
muss es weiter beibehalten werden weil
auch die 19 % für Schul und
kinderspeisung in den Schulen draufken
wird also wenn auch diese Preise für
Familien weiter steigen Werte
Bundesregierung sie alle Irlich dann
durch den politischen Alltag sie haben
keine Konzepte keine Ziele aber sie
haben es mit ihrer stuhlkreispolitik
mittlerweile geschafft dass übermoral
und schwarz-weiß denken wieder
gesellschaftsfähig sind sie versprechen
allen alles und können davon so ziemlich
wie nichts halten und deshalb liebe
Kollegen es liegt auf der Hand diese
Ampel sollte sie noch lange so bestehen
steht dauerhaft auf rot und damit auf
Stillstand deutschland braucht
Veränderung deutschland braucht die
Alternative vielen Dank
Tino kopaler Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD und weil
das in den abgelaufenen Minuten nicht
immer ganz klar geworden ist wir sind
eigentlich in der Aussprache zur
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
zum Europäischen Rat morgen und
übermorgen in Brüssel heute Abend schon
westbalkangipfel und